parce que nos vies se transforme
perpétuellement nous avons le devoir de
recycler tous ces matériaux yprema votre
partenaire pour un développement durable
bonjour et bienvenue dans équilibre le
magazine l'environnement et du
développement durable
au sommaire de ce numéro nous avons
rencontré une botaniste du muséum
national d'histoire naturelle de paris
pour nous parler de ces plantes que l'on
peut trouver au bord d'une route
derrière moi peuvent découvrir tous les
deux mois la biodiversité des alentours
ce mois ci c'est celle de l'étang des
roues siècle est à l'honneur tout
d'abord quand on parle de
l'environnement on pense surtout à
l'instant présent et au futur mais à
l'université versailles saint quentin
gregory kane est en étudie le passé il
est historien de l'environnement et nous
l'avons rencontré grégory kenneth vous
êtes historien d'environnement à
l'université versailles saint quentin
mais déjà ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer
ce qu'est un historien de
l'environnement un historien
d'environnement c'est un historien qui
pensent que l'histoire n'est pas fait
simplement par les sommes que la nature
ce qu'on appelle les non humains les
arbres les plantes ne sont pas là en
attendant qu'on les utilise ce conte et
classifie quand les transforme mais
qu'ils ont une forme d' agent tivité
propres et que faisant ceci est bien il
le transforme une faune aussi ce qu'est
notre société notre système politique
comment travaillez vous je parle
généralement des archives en fait je
travaille son environnement une c'est un
travail sur l'invisibilité sait comment
faire que ce que l'on ne voit plus qui
est sous nos yeux
qui sont ces traces cette matérialité
bien les rendre à nouveau visible c'est
ce que je fais dans mon livre sur
l'histoire un grand talent du château de
versailles un versailles histoire
naturelle aux éditions la découverte
s'est montré comment versailles a été en
fait loin du thème habituel du contrôle
de la nature nature de le nature dominé
par les hommes à partir du jardin a été
un lieu qui était un parc de chasse
on a inventé la régénération des animaux
on a pensé un contrat social autour de
la reproduction de ces animaux et des
droits des hommes
un véritable laboratoire
environnementale mais tout est là dans
les archives mais il faut le rendre à
nouveau visible et en quoi est-ce
important finalement de connaître
l'histoire de l'environnement c'est
important parce qu'en fait cette
matérialité et elle est toujours là en
fait de manière de manière invisible et
souterraines prenez par exemple ce
qu'est une ville une ville est bien est
toujours au départ une implantation
humaine sur un site naturel et donc il
ya une forme d'assemblage d'alliance en
fait qui conditionne le choix et la
forme que cette ville prend la manière
dont saint quentin en yvelines a été une
ville au chant par exemple eh bien elle
est toujours là dans les rapports entre
les habitants dans le type
d'organisation politique c'est une forme
d'assemblage de configuration qui
continuent à exercer ces effets
aujourd'hui et au niveau national
international est ce qu'il y à des
événements marquant le premier événement
marquant c'est c'est l'impérialisme et
la colonisation du monde sait comment
l'expansion européenne et bien modifier
profondément les différents écosystèmes
qu'il va dire qu'ils avaient en face
d'eux c'est des choses comme la
diffusion des de certains animaux qui
n'existaient pas ils ont des lapins des
rats des araignées
c'est la destruction environnementale
des sociétés auxquelles est comment dire
que les que le dans les européens
prenaient prenez possession et c'est
aussi la découverte d'une certaine
fragilité de la nature parce qu'en fait
il faut bien voir que ce qu'on a fait
pendant des siècles c'est qu'au fur à
mesure de l'expansion
il ya en prenez possession d'un
territoire on l'exploité de manière
assez outrancière et puis on l'abandonné
pour passer à un autre une fois qu'il
était épuisé notre événement marquant
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'anthropocène
les changements climatiques et
environnementaux globaux qui
apparaissent avec la révolution
industrielle
et bien aujourd'hui une des difficultés
que l'on a c'est que bien finalement ça
ne marche plus on peut plus on n'a
qu'une seule planète
est ce qu'on a appris à faire parlant
des siècles c'est à dire à se déplacer
eh bien on peut plus reproduire
dernière question
dans les mois à venir il y aura le kop
21 la conférence mondiale
qu'en attendez vous je suis comme
beaucoup de personnes assez assez
réservé sur les résultats pratiques que
cela pourra donner
j'en attends finalement deux choses la
première c'est que c'est l'occasion s'il
s'agit de repenser les politiques de la
terre c'est l'occasion de nouer de
nouvelles alliances de nous un nouvel
géopolitiques autour des questions
environnementales et finalement ce sera
un premier résultat
le deuxième résultat c'est que j'en
attend peut-être du demi-échec que ça a
des chances d'être une sorte de prise de
conscience de la manière dont peut-être
faut-il arrêter la thématique de
l'urgence est considéré que si nous
devons changer nos sociétés profondément
et bien et cela se faire dans le temps
cela se faire par l'ensemble des acteurs
pas forcément par des négociations
internationales en modifiant le cadre de
pensée et c'est là que l'histoire jouent
un rôle parce que justement il faut il
faut pour savoir où on veut aller et
bien savoir d'où on vient et c'est ce
que j'attends tous les deux mois la
maison de quartier dans les parcs à la
verrière en galice des randonnées pour
apprendre la faune et la flore de 50 ans
nul et ce mois ci c'était la
biodiversité de l'étang des routières de
guyancourt qui était à l'honneur
elodie moelle et mickaël mille euros
nous la font découvrir donc c'est un
bassin seul principe qui paraît pas du
tout intéressant en matière de
biodiversité et qui fait des matières en
fait tous les scientifiques puisque au
final à des espèces un petit peu
notables qui arrivent à se reproduire
les temps des rousses hier à guyancourt
un trésor caché à une centaine de mètres
seulement de l'université versailles
saint quentin ce bassin est créée en
1978 avec la vie nouvelle pour réguler
les eaux pluviales
c'est dans ce décor sauvage que la
maison cartier d'orly par cas la
verrière a organisé une randonnée verte
réservé aux habitants de la commune
il est quand même au sein d'un espace
calme urbain on a à l'université de 50
ans que juste à côté on a skywest
on a des autoroutes pas très très loin
donc c'est assez
moi qui viens pas forcément dit si par
exemple je trouve que c'est assez
intéressant de se dire que les espèces
arrivent à se développer malgré nos
activités autour a bien un héros caché
je penserai si vous regardez on le voit
même à l'oeil nu
ça c'est un héron cendré on dit qu'il a
un régime alimentaire et chauffage tout
simplement pourquoi parce qu'en pâtisse
voilà il se nourrit de poissons et les
ronds faut savoir que sa niche en
hauteur ça ne me choque pas au sol sa
niche en hauteur ça dans ce qu'on
appelle des héronnières donc la
démission des arts en fête l'étang
grande 5 ha rassemble diverses espèces
oiseaux poissons ou encore amphis bien
aux randonneurs roxane ogi présente gg
comprenez le geris une punaise aquatique
patineurs qui si les temps étaient
vraiment réellement polluer ne pourrait
pas patiné à la surface de l'eau tout
simplement pourquoi on dit qu'il est bio
indicateurs en fait ils patinent sur
l'eau par la poussée superficiel en fait
pour imaginer que toutes les gouttes
d'eau sont recouvertes d'une pellicule
et que le jour où cette pellicule est
rompue l'ag risque plus en fait patiner
dessus pour découvrir toute la foule
présente au roussienne il fallait
parfois chercher sous l'eau à l'aide
d'une épuisette ces apprentis
explorateurs ou pu également observer la
vie sous-marine de l'étang et notamment
des l'a22 loisel proches parents des
libellules le prochain rendez vous est
programmé en juin les randonneurs vers
hyérois visiteront les étangs de
saint-hubert opérait en yvelines cette
fois ci la guide leur fera découvrir le
chant des oiseaux
vous les trouvez peut-être disgracieux
césaire des plantes qui poussent au sein
même de nos villes elles sont de plus en
plus nombreuses notamment grâce à
l'arrêt de l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires
elles sont aujourd'hui répertoriés par
l'observatoire sauvages de ma rue du
muséum national d'histoire naturelle et
pour en parler nous sommes avec gabriel
martin bonjour gabriel vous vous êtes
chargé de projet floristique au muséum
oui alors
est ce que pouvait me dire ce qu'on peut
trouver dans nos villes alors dans les
villes on peut trouver énormément de
plantes sauvages
donc on en trouve 250 tr commune et
après ça peut aller
enfin on peut retrouver beaucoup des
espèces plus remarquable dans certains
endroits
ici vous avez par exemple une espèce de
rhumes de d'oseille donc une oseille
qu'on appelle rumex en latin donc ici
les feuilles étaient consommés et
peuvent être encore donc on l'est on est
préparé un peu comme des feuilles
d'épinard vous avez derrière donc une
plante que qu'on connaît tous très bien
parce qu'on s'est piqué plusieurs fois
avec donc c'est lortie lortie dioïque
urtica dioica donc c'est une espèce qui
a des usages multiples donc notamment
qui est un aliment un aliment très
important pour plusieurs espèces de
papillons et en plus qu'il ya des usages
médicinaux reconnu
et anciens ici encore vous avez une
espèce qui s'appelle le gaillet
gratteront donc gallium à paris né en
latin donc ça c'est une espèce voiliers
qui s'accroche donc aux vêtements comme
au pelage des animaux et qui à
dispersion donc on appelle cette
dispersion de type 2 au corps donc les
prix vont être dispersés par les animaux
de cette façon en s'accrochant tout à
l'heure je disais on en trouve de plus
en plus mais est ce que c'est vrai ou
finalement elles ont toujours été là et
en fait on les regardait pas on n'en
trouve pas forcément de plus en plus
elles ont toujours été là est justement
c'est ce qu'on voit avec cet arrêt de
l'utilisation de ces produits
la banque de graines s'exprime et donc
c'est bien que les graines étaient là ou
alors que les espèces ne peuvent se
disperser en ville et donc s'installer
dans des milieux on les attendait pas
donc ces espèces ont
un des rôles très importants dans les
communautés dans lesquelles elle
s'insère donc d'une part donc les
plantes sont à la base des communautés
sein des réseaux trophiques des
écosystèmes donc c'est une source de
nourriture pour énormément d'insectes
donc après d'insectes pollinisateurs ou
de d'autres d'autres types d'animaux
doit jouer notamment leur présence est
importante en ville pour justement
maintenir c'est les fonctions de ces
écosystèmes et notamment les services
qu'on appelle les services
écosystémiques donc ils sont produits
par la nature et qui qui ont un rôle
capital notamment dans le bien-être et
la santé des citadins
on vient de voir quelques espèces pour
les découvrir
l'observatoire est actuellement en train
de les recenser mais est ce que vous
pouvez me parler un peu de cet
observatoire
c'est un observatoire de science
participative donc un programme de
science participative c'est c'est un
programme qui est initié lancé par une
équipe de recherche et donc qui propose
à un public ciblé de s'impliquer dans
l'observation de la nature dans notre
cas est donc là dans le cas de
l'observatoire sauvages de ma rue donc
l'équipe de recherche du muséum national
d'histoire naturelle propose donc à tout
citadin de s'impliquer bénévolement et
de choisir une rue de faire l'inventaire
de la flore de cette rue donc on est ou
pas des connaissances en botanique
derrière martin vous remercier pour
toutes ces explications
merci roue
comme chaque mois noté ces quelques
rendez vous du 18 au 22 mai la ville de
trappes organise une semaine spéciale
environnement avec ateliers conférences
et rai écologique
n'hésitez pas à vous rendre sur le site
de la comul pour voir tout le programme
c'est le mois du recyclage à la maison
de l'environnement qui propose divers
ateliers
le 23 mai vous pouvez ainsi créer votre
jardin avec des matériaux de
récupération c'est de 14 heures à 18
heures et dès l'âge de 3 ans le samedi
30 mai vous pourrez rencontrer insectes
rongeurs et champignons qui sont des
recycleurs
la forêt s'est organisée par l'office
national des forêts pensez à vous
inscrire et les 6 et 7 juin à la
verrière se déroulera le festival
alternatiba 50 ans ighil au programme
ateliers exposants conférences pour
réfléchir à des solutions concrètes face
aux changements climatiques
et voilà équilibre c'est terminé je vous
donne rendez vous le mois prochain et
d'ici là
pensez à faire un geste pour
l'environnement